Mother made some pancakes for billy
about the dragon,
ate the mall,
mother made some more,
but the dragon eight,
those two mother kept making pancakes
until she ran out of batter.
Billy only got one of them,
but he said that's all he really wanted.
Anyway,
so I'll tell you another story about
that.
So when I lived in Boston,
I had little kids and uh,
my wife took care of some neighborhood
little kids because she didn't have a
green card and that was,
she was home with the kids anyways.
And anyway,
she took care of some other little kids.
One of them would only eat hot dogs.
That was quite funny.
You'd only eat hotdogs at his mother's
place booked at our house.
He ate all of his lunch and he was
perfectly happy about it.
So I thought that was quite amusing too.
But anyways,
one day a neighbor came by and the
neighbor had a four year old child and
the neighbor was looking for someone to
take care of the child because her nanny
had been in a car accident and couldn't
take care of the child temporarily.
So the child had sort of been
circulating around neighborhood houses
for a couple of days and you know,
people were taking care of him,
then he ended up at our house and um,
which was fine.
And so he's a cute little guy and uh,
his,
the mother came to the door and she said
she's,
you know,
pushed the boy and he was Kinda like,
this wasn't very happy.
And um,
she said he probably won't eat all day,
but that's okay.
And I thought,
hmm,
that's a,
that's a remarkably interesting
statement to,
you know,
to,
to put forth as a proposition the first
time we meet your son,
it's like he won't eat all day,
which by the way is not okay,
it's not okay and you're going to tell
us that it's okay and you're going to
expect that we're just going to accept
the fact that you think it's okay.
And that's,
that's the whole story.
You deliver all that information in one
little sentence.
So I thought,
well,
that's pretty damn peculiar.
Uh,
I believe she was a psychologist too,
which was quite interesting.
So.
Okay,
so that's fine.
So I went out to do something and there
was four kids playing in the house and
when I came back the little guy was in
the porch,
like wear the boots were at everything
and he was sort of standing there like
this and I thought,
hmm,
that's not good because there's all
these other kids.
Like he should've been in there playing
a lot obviously that that's what a child
is primed to do.
He should've been in there messing about
with,
I think there was a two year old,
a three year old and another four year
old.
He should've been in there,
you know,
causing trouble and having fun and
playing.
But he wasn't,
he was standing in the porch like this
and he wasn't happy.
He wasn't happy.
So I looked at him for a bit and then I
poked him a couple of times because I
thought,
you know,
if you're interacting with little kids,
they're very playful a,
they're kind of like puppies.
And so if you,
if you tease them a bit and tickled them
a bit,
then usually even if they're crabby,
you know,
a smile break out that despite their
best efforts and then they'll sort of
giggle then maybe you know,
they'll try to whack you away and they,
you know,
they,
they go into a play routine and although
you may not know it,
mammals like us have a place circuit in
also.
So we're intrinsically playful,
which is partly why we can get along
with dogs because of course dogs are
intrinsically playful and most people
know how to play with the dog and you
know,
when a dog wants to play,
right?
Because it sort of puts his paws down
and looks up at you and Sorta grants and
puts its tail in the air and goes like
dance.
It's like clue in primate,
you know,
it's time to engage in some playing and
you basically know how to do that.
And even the dog knows how to do that.
So I'm poking this kid and trying to get
them to smile,
but there's no damn way,
you know,
I'm poking him.
He's just ignoring me like mad and I
thought,
that's not good,
you know,
because you don't want your four year
old to have learned that you should.
You should,
that it's okay to ignore adults or that
you should ignore adults or that you can
ignore adults.
That's all bad because the world's full
of adults and they know a lot of things
and they control all the resources and
so you better get along with them.
Plus you're going to end up as an adult
for most of your life.
So if the general,
you know,
if the first rule is adults can and
should be ignored,
then what the hell are you headed for?
You know,
and it's one of the reasons that it's
really useful to made sure the children
respect adults because they're going to
be adults.
So if they don't respect adults,
then of course they don't have any
respect for what they're going to be.
Why the hell grow up?
You end up like Peter Pan Because that's
what Peter Parents about,
right?
Peter Pan Wants to stay at Neverland
with the lost boys were where there's no
responsibility because you know,
he looks at the future and only sees his
captain hook a tyrant who's afraid of
death.
That's the crocodile,
right?
It's chasing him with a clock in its
stomach.
And it's the same thing as this dragon.
So,
you know,
kids have to respect adults.
It's,
you're doing them a disservice if they
don't.
So okay,
so fine.
I'm poking this kid.
There's just no damn way.
I'm not getting anywhere with them and I
thought this isn't good.
There's something deeply wrong with this
little kid,
so that's fine.
So then we said all the kids down for
lunch and the rule is your damn lunch
and be thankful for it because you think
about this.
Leonard Cohen wrote this song once
about,
I don't remember the song particularly,
but he talked about the homicidal
bitching that goes down in every kitchen
about who is going to serve and who's
going to eat.
It's like if you haven't encountered
that,
then there's something terribly wrong.
You know,
so because a lot of the tension in in
households is domestic tension,
the tension between husbands and wives
or husbands,
wives and children.
It's like just who the hell is going to
do the domestic duties and how and when
and the answer can't be,
well,
we're not going to do them because then
you know,
you eat cheetos and popcorn and you
know,
for the rest of your life and that's not
good.
It's gotten to the point in England
because the domestic situations have
deteriorated.
The rituals have deteriorated to such a
point that about one slash third of
families no longer have a dining room
table and you can buy precooked hard
boiled eggs.
Yeah,
yeah.
Right.
You know,
it's not a good thing.
And you might ask yourself why the hell
everyone is either fat or has an eating
disorder.
And you know,
part of the reason is,
is that the entire domestic routine
around regulating food intake has
disappeared.
And that's a terrible thing for people
because we're social eaters.
So you might say,
well if you sit down with a bunch of
other people at a table,
how much should you eat?
And the answer is you should eat on
average what everyone else eats.
And that's exactly what you do.
Even if you don't notice it,
you know,
people are so wired into.
We did experiments like this.
If you,
if you bring on have you bring
undergraduates who don't know each other
into a lab and you give them a snack
while they're doing something like
watching a movie,
they will eat the same number of chips.
So you know,
if one of the meets the whole half the
thing,
the other real you'd have if one only
has one,
the other only have one.
The correlation between the food intake
between the dyads was about point eight.
It was staggering.
It seemed to be a little higher for
extroverts than for introverts,
but it was remarkably remarkably can
coordinate and you can understand why,
right?
Because human being shared food,
it's like you are not going to be a
popular tribes person if you eat,
you know,
30 percent of the food when food is in
short supply,
you better be bloody awake and make sure
that you don't take more than your share
and you know,
it's a fundamental element of human
nature to do that.
And,
and we also regulate our sense of
satiety by cues that are external to us.
So regulating our food intake also
because we're omnivores,
turns out to be a tremendously difficult
thing and well,
anyways,
back to this kid.
So we bring all the kids to the table
and they're sitting around in there
having lunch and the rule is,
as I said,
eat what is in front of you and be
pleased and happy about it.
So you might say,
well why would that also be a rule?
It's like,
okay,
put yourself in this position now
because you'll be in this position.
You're going to cook your damn kids some
lunch and you're going to do that.
Well,
let's,
let's calculate it out because I like
doing arithmetic.
So let's say it takes you half an hour a
day and you do it seven days a week,
but we'll multiply that by three because
there's three meals.
So it's an hour and a half a day,
right?
So okay,
fine.
Seven times an hour and a half is
roughly 10.
So it's 10 hours a week.
It's 40 hours a month,
right?
Forty hours a month is a full work week.
So 40 hours a month times 12,
12 full work weeks,
right?
Yes.
That's three full months of 40 hour days
of cooking something for your damn kid.
Now that's a lot of time and then you're
going to do that for 18 years.
So then you might ask yourself what sort
of response do you need from your child
in order to not feel resentful and
miserable about the fact that you have
to do that for three bloody months this
year and you just have to think about
this and this is also why it's necessary
to know inside yourself.
You carry a monster just like the world
outside you carries a monster.
Do not think that you're going to be
able to maintain a healthy attitude
towards your child or towards food or
towards yourself.
If all you can muster up for the effort
of cooking and preparing food is the
attitude of a slave and continual
punishment from the people that you're
offering food too.
It's like,
who the hell wants that?
So you want to teach them miserable
little bladder that he's lucky that
there's any food there at all and that
the proper attitude is to say,
really thank you very much mom or thank
you very much dad.
I'm glad that you produce something and
then you know,
you can be all happy about the fact that
you were slaving away in the kitchen and
you can like your kid.
So,
and you know,
you might think,
well everybody likes their kids.
It's like,
yeah,
right.
No that's not true.
That's not true.
And now,
and then,
you know,
you read in the newspaper about someone
who's,
you know,
being pushed a little bit too far on
some day that they're unemployed and
hung over and you know,
the relationship is just broken up and
they do something absolutely brutal to
their child.
And you think,
well,
how could anyone do that?
It's like there's a lot of history of
terrible interactions between the mother
and the child or the father and the
child before something like that
happens.
So,
you know,
if you want to protect your child
against the beast that's inside you,
you might want to teach them to treat
you with some respect so that you're
much more likely to be a civilized human
being around them.
So,
all right,
so anyways,
so this kid sit in there and there's no
damn way he's going to eat anything.
So we decide we're going to feed him,
which I'm an expert at because my,
my son.
And the one who said no all the time,
he was the most stubborn little custom
you could possibly imagine.
And one time when he was about nine
months old,
he got ahold of the spoon and it was
like he was not going to be fat anymore.
Hey.
So that's fine.
Good.
You know,
it's like feed yourself,
but no kids say they're too damn curious
and playful really to feed themselves.
So you sit them in a high chair and
then,
you know,
they fling the food onto the floor
because that's pretty cool.
They could watch that over and over in
order they mess around with it or maybe
they,
you know,
put some in mum's hair because that's
interesting too.
And they have two or three bites and
then they're not ravenous and then
they're much more interested in playing
and that's fine except that kid does
need.
Then it gets crabby and you know,
whiny and miserable.
And then it just disturbs the mother or
the father and then it won't sleep at
night.
It's like,
that's no good.
So after about three days of that,
I took the spoon back from him and he
was not happy about that man trying to
get that little kid to eat.
Once I got the spoon,
it was like a four hour battle.
It was really remarkable.
So I,
I,
a lot of respect for his ability to
withstand stubbornness,
you know,
but I had learned by that time as a
parent that like if you want to
discipline your child,
you,
there's an attitude you have to take,
which is I am going to win this.
Like I don't care how stubborn you are,
I am going to win.
And because I know I'm going to win,
I'm not going to get angry.
I'm just gonna out stubborn you.
And so.
So I take up some food and put it in
front of him.
He'd go like this.
So that was a good trick.
And so I try to get the food in there
and his teeth regretted.
So I poke,
poke,
poke.
And after about 10 pokes,
he'd get annoyed and go and I put the
food yet then he tried to spit it out.
So I'd hold it,
the editing this.
So then.
So that was like three minutes,
you know,
and then we did it with another spoonful
and you know,
after about,
I'd say an hour of this,
my wife had to leave because it was like
she just couldn't handle it and I bought
an hour after this he decided that,
you know,
it was okayed and then he would let me
feed them.
But like it was brutal and it was
amazing.
I mean little kids are so damn tough,
you know,
they're really cute and everything and,
but they're so tough you just can't
believe it.
So anyways.
So we had this good at the table and he
was not going to eat.
So my wife who'd learned these tricks by
this time decided to feed him and he had
a lot of sort of nine months old or
eight month old behaviors because you
don't.
Kids have different strategies of
resistance if they don't want to do
something and those strategies get more
sophisticated as they get older.
But.
And he had some strategies but they
weren't sophisticated,
you know,
like he didn't make jokes or knocked the
spoon away or,
or get angry or,
or run away or any of those things.
He did kind of nine months old things,
which means he just put his head down
and when she put the spoon towards him,
he just covered his head one way or
another.
So.
So that was interesting because I knew
that his parents had given up feeding
him when he was about eight or nine
months old because those tricks worked.
And so that's why she could come to the
house and say he probably won't eat all
day,
but that's all right.
Which it isn't,
it's not all right.
So fine.
So my wife is trying to feed him and he
doesn't open his mouth so she pokes him
a bit and sooner or later he gets mad
and you know,
goes and she puts the food in and she
does.
And then she pats him on the head as
soon as he swallows it and says,
look,
you're being a really good kid.
You know,
you're doing a good job.
And then,
so he's wondering what the hell is going
on.
And then it was so interesting because
she kept feeding him and he was still
doing this,
but as she patted them on the head,
he'd be doing this and he'd open his
mouth.
So it was like there was this weird
conflict between his habitual behavior
and this thing that was being
reinforced.
So then she put food in and pat him and
he,
you know,
he'd be kind of happy about that.
And then he'd go back to his routine and
then she did that for I think about 20
minutes.
It wasn't disruptive like all the other
kids ate.
They didn't even really notice what was
going on.
It wasn't,
it wasn't a big deal,
you know,
but I was watching because I knew
something was up because the stupid
thing that his mother said and then the
fact that he wouldn't play and he
ignored me,
I thought,
Nah,
there's some reading not good here,
this dragon here.
And it's a big one.
So she feeds him and then he finishes
the whole bowl.
It's like.
And she says,
you're a good boy.
You ate the whole bowl and Jesus,
you should have seen what happened to
that kid.
Man,
it just about broke my heart,
like really,
like his eyes got big and he smiled and
he was just like,
he was super thrilled because he'd
finally accomplished this absolute basic
necessity that he hadn't mastered in
four years.
He finally got it right.
You think of all the meals that he went
through either being ignored or failing
three times a day for like three years,
nothing but failure and bad responses
and you know,
he didn't turn light all that.
He thought he was a bad kid and then all
of a sudden he figured this out and you
know,
get a little reward for.
It was like he just lit up and that
whole shell that he had on the that he
was like using to protect himself when
he was in the porch.
That just melted away.
It was like,
it was horrifying and amazing at the
same time.
And then he followed my wife around
after that in the house,
just like a puppy dog,
like he wouldn't get.
He would not get more than one foot away
from her.
It was unbelievable.
And then we went downstairs to watch
like a movie with the kids and she sat
on a rocking chair and he climbed right
up on her lap and grabbed her just like
that.
Harlow monkey grabbed the,
you know,
the little soft mother instead of the
winery mother for teams like this.
And he was like that for like two hours.
He wouldn't let her go.
So then the mother came home,
his mother came home and she came
downstairs and she looked at what was
going on,
you know,
when this kid was like glommed onto my
wife and she looked at her and she said,
oh supermom.
And you know,
took her kid and went home.
It's like Jesus,
like if you don't think there's a dragon
and that story,
man,
you are not listening to it.
It was not good.
And her response at the end was
terrible.
She should've said,
well,
how do you get them to eat?
It's like,
what?
What the hell is he doing?
Like,
hugging you?
He never does that to me.
No way man.
She was going to let that piece of
information in and it's no wonder
because the dragon and that story was
her and it was something she did not
want to admit and she was willing,
perfectly willing to sacrifice her child
to that,
to her failure to realize that she could
be a dragon.
So that meant that the child was the
problem and that's a hell of a thing to
do to a four year old.
So it was not pleasant.
It was really not pleasant.
In fact,
we probably did damage to the child by
actually getting them to do something
good day because we opened up him up to
the possibility that he could behave
properly and be rewarded for that.
And that gave them hope.
And so you can bloody well be sure that
that hope was dispensed with the next
day.
So.
And that's why bill,
he doesn't get anything to eat.